voici italie les yukes la déesse de la
mer pour les inuits
une des pièces maîtresses de cette
exposition c'est dans la mythologie
inuit le personnage le plus fabuleux le
plus raconté de génération en génération
et les communautés inuit y ont cru dur
comme fer à cette déesse mi humaine mi
poisson qui régnait sur le monde marin
le morse le hibou le phoque sont des
animaux sacrés pour les inuits manas
italia piquent leur rend hommage dans
ses sculptures qui raconte limiter les
légendes de son peuple
il aime aussi représenter les conteuses
et des chamans personnage important pour
les inuit
né en 1955 dans un village de la terre
de bas fin au nunavut dans le grand nord
canadien
cet artiste inouk qui est un autodidacte
vit maintenant près de toronto
mais chaque été il retourne dans sa
terre natale pour y puiser la matière
première de ces sculptures des os de
baleine des bois de caribou et autres
vestiges d'animaux de la faune arctique
de la forme de ce morceau d'os qui a
inspiré l'artiste
l'artiste vous voyez son artère son
intervention est minime c'est une
imagination incroyable
ce sont des oeuvres remarquables
l'heure aussi servi de thérapie pour
mana ci qui a vécu le traumatisme des
pensionnats autochtones quand il était
enfant
un traumatisme qu'il transcende dans ses
oeuvres comme cette sculpture baptisée
la peur de perdre sa culture
ce qu'on voit c'est un chaman un chaman
dont le visage est fendue en deux à
cause des exactions commises par les
peuples du sud qui ont forcé des
générations entières d'inuits à se
couper de leur culture à se couper de
leur langue
[Musique]
cette culture inuit qui l'a préservé ce
virtuose de la sculpture veut la
transmettre aux siens et il l'a fait
rayonner aussi sur la scène
internationale l'une de ses oeuvres
magistrales la création du monde est au
musée des confluences à lyon en france
il n'y a rien de semblable lignards dans
de pareils faits pièces sont uniques au
monde
des oeuvres puissantes bouleversante
d'une grande beauté que le musée
national des beaux-arts du québec 20
jours intégré dans sa collection
permanente ici catherine françois radio
canada québec